[Music]
the thickening is upon you
with our necks combined
nothing can stop us
go now to the description
youtube.com
you won't
okay oh oh no
wait oh crap okay
uh hello everybody my name is markiplier
apparently i'm back
at the base i closed out of my game
before
and i guess it hasn't saved
since i went out on my adventure so i'm
back
here which is good actually
that means i can try to look here okay
i'm gonna do that hey
we got a second chance at not making a
stupid oh i'm sorry about that
but i also did think of something uh in
between
i got not only a decapitated head
of my former friend but also i got
another key to the underground what i
didn't realize
is i don't think this is the same key
that i
had to get over here this guy had a key
the whole time he just didn't give it to
me that's how he got over here
in the first place maybe maybe that's
how i'm not 100 sure
anyway so now i got another chance to go
up here i checked all the places due
west so i'm just going to go up here and
check up
in the top north east
yes northeast direction oh
did i kill someone over here apparently
i killed someone over here but i don't
remember doing that
apparently oh yeah the big old fire pile
what is on the fire what are they
burning exactly
bodies i don't think i want to know you
know i don't think i want to know and i
i
it doesn't bother me one way or another
what they want to do with their free
time is what they do hello
with the oh there's a chest over there
okay
i could open it with a lock pick uh well
you know lock picks are few and far
between torches are
in healthy supply yum
yum yum easy
lots of goodies okay good thank you
found the sawmill the sawmill
well oh
if i was hoping for wood this might be
the place
but i'm not really in a dire need for
wood
but it's oh doctor oh doc oh hey doc
oh the doctor turns his mud-covered head
towards the sun and freezes
then he spreads his arms along his sides
warm
a chunk of muds falls down on his
exposed tongue
he chews it slowly and swallows with
satisfaction
okay doctor puts the muddy hand into his
mouth grimaces and pulls out a yellow
tooth
he puts it into the pocket of his torn
trousers the tooth falls through a hole
he does not notice this
the doctor begins staring in a nearby
tree trunk paying no attention to the
blood flowing between his lips the
doctor glances at me he tilts his head
sideways lost in thought
after a moment he extends his hand
towards me as if wanting to grab me by
the throat
but stops halfway he freezes slowly he
bends down and grabs a thick branch from
the ground
he starts biting the bark off of it he
swallows the bark with an effort
but also great satisfaction he places
the stick among the other ones sticking
out of his mud-covered head the doctor
approaches me i can feel him embracing
me i hear his horse breath and smell his
odor and i hear him whisper
soon very soon not long from now
all right man hey good you know i don't
need the weapon parts i don't need the
barrel i'll pick the
i'll take the embryo you know all right
okay hey uh
all right stay um
stay stay good stay good stay good stay
good uh is there anything else here
or is this the only is it just wood is
it just logs
logs here logs there just all the
oh logs
i got a bunch of logs
oh boy oh no i need a key
oh good okay so um
yeah the sawmill um definitely
needs some work that's that's fine
that's probably fine
okay so that's not where the quarry was
then it must be down here
bottom right way south which means that
i went the wrong way again which is fine
whatever [ __ ] happens
oh okay hey bud look
you deserve death death
a death thank you for complying
hate you but not the worst one worst
one's still exploding man
or the swamp beast
painful oh
well you know what actually i never
should have gone there in the first
place thinking now
may have been a
[Music]
thank you for playing my game okay i'm
back home
well that's something
i'm so full of crap okay
ah fine okay so i bend down here because
there's a dead dude i put
oh i put away the bigger stack of i'm an
idiot
i put away the big stack of pills
instead of taking the little
the big the putting away the big hello
hi i'm gonna dig you up
hey that is running pills
i like them what the hell was that
hello oh i don't want to know
i don't care i don't want to know i
don't want to know
i found the great lake oh my god the
great lake
holy crap the lake is great that is a
great lake all right good
good lake man good lake oh oh
did we find it yes we did
okay good hey remember me
i killed your pig your only source of
food in this nightmare world
i killed it it deserved to die we don't
want you here too late here i am
nah can't can't [ __ ] me off can't do it
no way
oh another gutted pig that's lovely your
decorations
are phenomenal just as we manage
breakthrough our way
back gets blocked yeah that's what
happens we're gonna starve here
nah there's tons of food hey i do oh
[ __ ] oh they do not like me
oh god they they actually oh wait hey
hey
oh my god i see a locker i see a locker
with my uh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
okay you know what hey you've had a
rough day
of things you've had rough time you need
just need to think it out because this
is clearly
it's like the only way to the old quarry
okay
all right hey buds how's it going listen
don't be mad at me
don't be mad at no oh they're mad at me
oh they are mad oh they are still mad
they're shockingly still mad at me
i'll take what's in potatoes i'm taking
your food i'm taking all your food
but i won't kill you because that'd be
mean what do we have here what is this
is this the way they dug out was it all
blocked up again oh oh
hey i don't want to kill you hi oh god
oh god goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye hello goodbye oh god uh you know
maybe i should what is it what oh my god
what's a little killed pig between
friends
oh hey friends uh
okay this is dead end listen
pal i don't want to go on a murdering
rampage through this whole thing
i just wanted to make amends bring you
food and whatnot
oh the oh my god oh hi
who are you what are you doing here uh
hey he's here help um
you know they they cut down a lot of
trees they could try to build a bridge
to get to you
oh man he's stuck he stuck amy you could
try to build a bridge
interesting what if i uh what if i go
stealthy like you know
what if i sneak in will they will they
notice me if i don't have a big
bright shiny light they do not seem to
be doing okay
oh god he noticed ah turns out they
notice
oh he stopped noticing perfect
i will steal your things now i will take
them
pitchfork i don't really need them but
all of your potatoes are not mine
it's just the way things go law of the
jungle law of the land
don't feel bad for yourselves feel bad
for me oh yeah that's
that's sneaky oh that's sneaky okay i
wonder if i could sneak in the back way
here and grab
nope i wonder if they could distract him
with meat you think that would do it
for him hey i'm uh oh look it's uh
it's me they noticed really quickly
it knows really quickly all right and oh
hey
okay and now i'm gonna go get the yeah
it's all mine baby
it's all mine baby i take your potatoes
all of your potatoes are mine
i took literally all of their potatoes
uh well they were gonna starve anyway
so um i am now rich with potatoes which
is pretty
dope okay well that was sad and also
really didn't help me
a lot how'd they get a truck over here
okay well yeah i got potatoes now which
is not really what i was going for
but you know i'll take them i just munch
them on my way back i guess
oh tasty potato okay so what's up with
this great lake by the way that's
fascinating
probably i also need the oxygen tank for
which means i gotta find where the
oxygen tank
is i'm not 100 sure where that is
because i i fixed the compressor i just
don't have any oxygen tanks
probably if i go into the the village i
should go in there because i went there
first
and then i kind of like pussied out of
there because it was terrifying
and i didn't want to go in there but i
should because that's probably um
the only place left to go i've got tons
of supplies
in this area here i've kind of farmed up
everything so i think it's time to move
forward
i think there's a talking tree that i
need to converse with
what am i gonna do with all these
potatoes
this is my potato wardrobe potato drobe
i'll eat these
tasty delicious potatoes repair that
that's great
i'll put the gas tank on the ground
that'd be nice
how you doing music man
hey how how are you
oh god sorry i didn't want to this thing
is coming out of my body
i tried to stop it but i don't think i
can now the whole room is covered with
this
i didn't want to make a mess i swear
please don't throw me away please let me
stay i promise to be good
please don't be angry with me anymore i
won't be angry with you
it's okay i it's fine look i get it
you uh you have a lovely time in there
and you stay safe because that's my
number one priority always
stay safe all right i've got bear traps
out the ass i'm gonna put them down
there's no reason anyone should be
coming in this window
this slurpetty blurpity and no one
should be coming this way
anyway so just forget about that uh
just in case i need to run a second
serpentine path
yeah smart me smart me let me make sure
i got gas for the thing
which i might not uh oddly no i don't i
might have forgotten to turn it off or
something
i'll put this uh here again
so that i can blast it um
i'll put it put it right here
okay now no one is going to mess with me
i am very secure i am very safe
night cycle let's do this i'm the most
prepared i've ever been
i know exactly what to do almost making
this too easy
hi birds hi
uh this is weird
wha what happened what happened why is
it dark why am i in the dark
oh hey oh my god how did you get in huh
i gotta switch
light it flat throughout that
okay good babies oh god i missed the
babies
i how how did oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh i'm trapped i'm trapped i'm
trapped for some reason my life's not
working i've gone through the fire i'm
on fire
fire on my phone where'd you come from
get out of here
i'm on fire i need to eat oh god there's
a bear trap
lucky man yay
hey hey hey hey hey hey no ouch
no no what how are you
are you still alive throw it boom
yeah in flames in flambe
how'd i miss the babies again get lit on
fire ah but they're on fire
they're on fire oh god the lights are
out why are the lights out
why are the lights out or the lights out
because why why are the lights out
why what's wrong with the generator
what's wrong with the generator oh god
uh hang on excuse me i gotta disarm this
i need to get through here apparently
this is the only working light
okay hey
that's great so that's apparently a
thing that all the lights will go out
except for one then i gotta go find the
light
and apparently my lantern won't work
that's really cool
okay that's fine man those shadows
really uh
really love me
who's oh god another one of you try me
try me try me try me try me and
sho oh god oh i got it never mind
oh good uh ow oh my god where's the
light
light please light light light
light there's no light light ah baby
hold the baby still
oh my god i'm stuck no you will not get
me this
night all right babies you wanna taste
uh
uh baby bottle full of lead
wow that sucked oh who
else knocks upon my door
on my chamber door a dog
doggy all right
whatever ah my bear trap god damn it
i really don't want the three to catch
me in a my own bear trap
i i didn't see it before honestly it was
so camouflaged i didn't i thought it was
triggered or something
apparently not all right hey buds wow
that night really didn't go to plan
uh turns out all the traps i put down
were really useless
this whole surviving thing i'm not the
best at it i'm i'm not gonna lie
not the best but hey i'm alive
and that's what really matters my dudes
my dudes thanks thank you
thank you you're too kind you're too
kind literally you are too kind you need
to back off
it is getting really uncomfortable all
right perfect rainy day for going to uh
the village
i'm gonna go i think talk to a tree uh
let me turn off the generator before i
do that
great let me also make more molotovs
you never know when you're gonna need a
molotov i
am almost out of gas whoa that's weird
i'm so used to having a surplus
kind of forgotten what it's like not to
have the shovel is technically fine but
i've been in situations where i need to
dig stuff up a lot these days
so i probably should just start doing
the ax and then carrying the shovel with
me
because it seems it wants me to use the
shovel for
some reason i don't know why okay
let's do this i'm just gonna reload i
know there's a bullet left but i'm just
gonna reload all right let's do this
we're going to the village no time to
waste
we farmed up enough we've prepared
enough
i am in the i don't like being in the
swamp
doormat filled with a flower pattern is
it wait is this grandma
locked i need the key i don't know what
this is all right whatever there's
there's so many keys
there's so many combinations in this
game there's so many different places
that
seem like things that i i need what are
you saying
there i didn't say anything man are you
carry on i'm gonna go ahead and uh
try to get to this tree we're talking
about
oh this looks good
oh it was right there oh it was
literally right there
oh no oh no no no no i'm good oh god no
no
no no no no no no no no no no no the
tree is gigantic its spark stays in
constant motion it swells up and
collapses into itself as if breathing
i see human silhouettes growing out of
the tree trunk they're also moving as if
gesturing in slow motion
yeah not slow enough dozens of mouth
repeat their lines simultaneously
creating a uniform noisy murmur
between the bows i catch a man's gaze
it's fixed on me
his body similarly to the other being
seems to form an integral part of the
tree his limbs are gnarled and his face
is
grotesquely deformed which one of these
uh are you talking about here i don't
they all seem to be looking at me so uh
yeah he's the only one to acknowledge my
presence his hand slowly raises pointing
to something on the horizon
above the roofs of the destroyed village
the man's lips are moving but the
ghastly murmur as the other voices
drowns out his words
kick the tree hoping that the voices
will go slightly look at the lips of the
person talking to me
yeah i'm not gonna touch that tree even
though the figure speaks sluggishly it
is too high for me to read its lips
properly
i think the one of the words is radio oh
well but wait what
i'm barely able to make out conversation
you took everything from us to shots
from an old man only the tip of his head
and one of his arms stick out you stole
it thieves
may the dogs piss on your faces right
next to him a woman's head wobbling from
side to side repeats we were hungry
we were hungry another figure hiding its
face under an enormous root lets out a
chilling shriek
quiet [ __ ] quiet leave us in peace
shut up
he's interrupted by the man next to him
his intestines hanging out from his
stomach
it was our common good it was meant for
all of us you stole it high above at the
top the crown two silhouettes hanging
side by side from their hands and legs
grown into the trunk or trying to bite
each other's faces off
wow okay wow um
wow oh that's a lot okay um
hey what do we have here oh good
oh put six potatoes josik's dead we're
down to 26 six potatoes half a loaf of
bread two liters of gasoline one potato
josiks
none minus five potatoes one dog three
potatoes minus four potatoes minus three
potatoes that doesn't
sound good basement hatch the hatch
leading to the basement is blocked from
the inside
mark suggests someone tried to break it
open i don't know what the basement is
i don't think i want to go to the
basement okay but we got another problem
entirely
we have to go all the way to the other
side of the swamp
again i sh why didn't i just talk to the
tree i would have known
uh i didn't know that i was like i'm
gonna back off but the tree was right
there i didn't know i thought it was a
whole another zone like the village you
loaded into a new oh
god oh god oh god i should save my one
bullet for you
girl hate you i hate you
what is this no it's the shrine all
right whoa different shrine
there's a sign of teeth it's partially
eaten maybe uh maybe getting the
wood eating power wasn't the best idea
in the world
i got a location apparently holes
gray good where am i
going where am i going i don't know what
is
this i don't know what is that i don't
know there's a generator here great i
don't know
oh good oh
good oh god oh my god oh my god you
scared me so poopily
oh you suck oh my god a whole oh wait i
where am i
why am oh no no no no no no red chomper
no
no no oh god i need to hit it
with the oh and you hit it with the ice
switch to the goddamn axe
i gotcha okay
locked i could open it with a lock pick
you know what why not let's do it
i'm already here i'm ex i regret it the
word thief has been scratching into the
floor
i regret it a lot actually funnily
enough i regret coming in here
oh photo of three
boys the word thief is on the photo
all right oh good
glad i came here good stuff i need to
get to the other side of the swamp
now ish immediately now i have to get to
the radio tower and i have to get back
which means i have to book it
i'm going to get home and then when i do
get home i'm going to grab my running
pills
probably cocaine and i'm going to slam
down every single one of those and i'm
gonna get on my way
where am i go i'm going the wrong way
i am so uh
okay uh cocaine got it cocaine is in the
bag in my hand
okay we're going oh here we go here we
go here we go this is it this is the one
this is the good stuff i don't know
who's in here but they're gonna get a
face full of axe
okay i'm here i've no
no
what was that oh
no oh no is that a nest
oh oh no
oh no
they're sleeping but any noise can wake
them oh then i shouldn't
slam an axe into their jugulars that
would be an inappropriate thing to do
oh i see well this isn't the right way
either all right so i just gotta walk
very calmly around them
easy breezy beautiful oh
a god another snail oh wait no it's it's
very dead
um easy breezy
uh oh [ __ ]
one of them pooped itself awake
certainly wasn't my running
oh hey babies hey babes
hey sleepy babies who's a sleepy baby
hopefully you 9 volt battery why not
this is electronics i might need that
okay i better hurry i'm i'm getting slow
on time
uh do i need to go in here and turn
something off do i need to act
i got there's got to be something i i
need to axe right
oh yeah definitely something needs
accent in here
oh yeah oh yeah you didn't hear that did
you
okay this
[Music]
okay this is fine
oh okay that's that's a problem see how
that's a problem
did you wake up no babies no no no
babies
babies please babies please oh my god
babies burning babies we got burning
baby alert we got a burning baby alert
all right babies burned successfully
i guess i could have opened that with a
lockpick that would have been much
smarter
no no oh hey listen you try me
number one try me number two don't try
me ow
i'm on fire oh that fire really hurts
apparently
okay uh yoinkus
yoinkus oh my god oh my god the quick
attack is nice
yoincus but it takes a lot of stamina
apparently
okay did i burn the rest of the bibbus
the babies won't be bothering me no more
oh i am not desperate enough for that
stone
no thank you i don't want it actually i
don't want it
no no no no no no
no oh god ow okay there was no need
yeah okay where am i
what am i doing where am i is there
a lot of bodies here all right
all right he's dead okay let me in i
don't know that
i don't know the code what are you
talking about code
i don't know the code how would i know
the code
how would i know a code my god how would
i know a code
i think i remember the code for this
store well i'd eight six
eight four why do you remember that how
do you remember that
eight six eight four i hope they haven't
changed it oh good
you remembered it i mean yes good okay
eight six eight
four right you remember this who
are i am a civilian radio
overgrown with roots yep it sure is
underground entrance to the tunnels oh
good
tunnels me love tunnels
me big love tunnels me love tunnels
bigly
me love tunnels hugely me hugely love
tunnels long military flashlight
probably very useful
uh that hours two people came via tunnel
via the hideout near the village 3c they
were attacked
3110 the hideout near village 3c has
been compromised at least 12 locals have
entered the hideout cellar mostly
mud-covered savages three among them
were wearing unusual clothing
weird rags we lost one man the door to
the tunnels had been shut
none of the locals managed to break
through further we're getting ready for
evac
130 hours evac successful the door was
locked with the code we're going home
how do i know this code the further path
of this tunnel is blocked by enormous
roots
and rubble why do i know the code
maybe a one-way road uh yeah okay you
know what sure
at least time is frozen down here only
one shot
what does that mean okay i found a
floodgate in the tunnel i'm afraid i
will have only one shot of getting
further down the passage i feel it will
re
lead me to the right place all right
sure yeah um if you feel so
we'll only open if i close the previous
one uh
okay i guess we're we're in it now okay
good
yeah i was hoping for being trapped in a
tunnel filled with what seems to be
noxious gas is filling my
lungs what is that what am i is that
mushroom that liver is covered
comes on some kind of fungus i can't use
it now i need to find a way to get rid
of the parasite first
i could try burning it i could burn it
oh my god hey look a shovel
oh good meat great thank you for the
meat
great you only have one
sorry you only have one chance what do
you mean i only have one chance
what are you saying i only have one
chance what does that mean
the door seems to be blocked from the
other side what do you mean i only have
one chance
how about i burn it that usually works
fire is usually the solution to all my
problems
hey i did it i'm passed out
i probably shouldn't have hit it close
up
i should have thought about that a
little more intensely
hey did you what a what
hello oh i have nothing oh i'm
this is probably a dream nightmare
okay
sure
sure
i can hear someone calling
incomprehensibly from the depths
of the corridor
tom come to me
okay whatever you say
ah shiny stone the words come to me have
been scratched
on the ground i see oh the walls are
fleshy there i don't like
that oh
yay shiny stone i like
shiny stone oh shiny stone this way
well what about what's this way i like
this way
this way is real good fleshy walls
got a bed here are you lost oh hey
pale withered skin hollow eyes teeth
black is night he looks dead all right
but he's still moving okay
uh no not lost just exploring exploring
my options
just checking all the all the
peripherals
fragments of bloody cloth lie on the
trunk
okay so there's a stone down there
what's up this way ah
oh
oh it's a loop-de-loop
oh you weren't there before i think
you've lost your way buddy buddy
oh you know you're probably right too
far switch on
okay yeah uh
i lost my way just exploring all the
options
shiny stone
okay
what do you think you're doing there uh
got lost poor fella
uh you know not really
not particularly okay you know yeah you
know
oh oh
oh that was a bad idea oh terrible
terrible
terrible idea oh my god terrible idea
terrible terrible terrible terrible
hello hi hello
oh my god dodge dodge dodge i can dodge
all day baby i can dodge all day i can
dodge all day
i can dodge all day all day baby
all day baby oh hey all day baby all day
baby
all day baby all day baby all day
all day baby all day i'm gone i'm gone
i'm out i'm out
oh water oh that's not good oh that's
not good
oh that's not good oh please
safety oh
wait a minute is this a tunnel from the
beginning of the game
oh hi an entry to a small seller maybe
the pantry
could open it with a lockpick i don't
have a lockpick
but i can make a lockpick this is the
doctor's house from the very beginning
of the game
unlocked shovel interesting looks like
it's time to lumpy dump
my way through here
bam hello
hi hello
hi
okay
[Music]
that's not a good sound that's not what
you want to hear oh hi oh it's is
me a metal table with leather belts and
straps oh
good good good good
a sturdy table leg you know i love to
see it
i love it i love to hear it i'd love to
see it
am i about to be attacked i'm ready for
it i'm ready
generator on there we go that's better
all right who wants a piece want some
who wants some of me oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'll try you i'll try yeah
yeah i'll do this let's do this let's
dance
let's dance let's stay puppy huh i ain't
afraid of you i ain't afraid you i ain't
afraid of you yeah i'll i'll do this all
day
okay you're tough okay wait hang on
sorry you dow
ow ow okay ow oh hey okay
uh uh oh god um window yes i'll go out
the window
this is perfect i'll go this way
perfect excellent i am the greatest
that ever okay maybe not the greatest
that ever lived oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god please
oh come on it's stuck i could force my
way out
come on there we go yes okay close it
behind close it behind
okay close good good good good good good
good great great great
uh now what this way
sure yeah
bandages okay i can make it through the
fleshy walls
which is cool oh is my table leg gone
oh they took my table leg those bastards
oh those bastards oh i don't like these
walls oh
the pulsations oh the pulsations
oh they're hearts oh
good god
oh my goodness
well uh oh wow
oh oh no no
no no no no no no
no no no no
nope nope nope nope
nope a million ways nope oh my god nope
i'll dodge you
i'll doubt you oh i didn't dodge you
that time but i'll dodge you
i'll do it i'll dodge you every single
time every single time
you ain't never gonna get through my
defenses i'll take this shiny stone
because i
that's how much of a bad oh my god i'm
running i'm running now
now is when i run where am i going where
am i going i don't know
oh this way apparently maybe
maybe no yes oh god oh i need to get out
oh i see i need to remember the way i
came well good thing i'm very good with
the directions
okay
hello hi how are you i'll take that
thank you
shiny stone for me none for you i can't
go that way
right come to me oh okay
were you serious about that because uh i
guess
uh do i need to go in the big mouth oh
god please
oh god oh wait oh oh my god okay lights
off i get it i get up
did i do it
[Music]
what what do you mean i
are you kidding me are you kidding me
did i [ __ ] it up the end
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you oh my god if that's holy
[ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] god are you
[ __ ] kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me
are you [ __ ] serious
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god
what the [ __ ] i am
so upset with that
that is such a cheap way to screw
someone over
this is my first time playing through
this game
and i did that entire thing perfectly
and i
understood that you need to go through
the mouth and i was
in there but apparently you can get
[ __ ]
chomped on and that's so unfair
that it like it's not even about
fairness it's just
cheap like it's fine if i make a mistake
and like i cause if i ran away from the
enemies wrong or i took a wrong turn or
whatever
but my i was that is literally the last
thing you do in that whole sequence
that is the last thing you do that is so
unfathomably unfair
i am i
that is pretty much ruined my experience
that's what that's done that has
ruined my experience
i'm ending this episode i i don't want
to say anything i'll regret
because i think the game is very good
but at the same time
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i'll come back
to this with a more level head
when i can thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye
you